who were the biggest winners and losers
of the sexual revolution in your
opinion it's a long story but I think
the biggest winners have been men and in
particular predatory men and I think the
biggest losers have been
romance men who are not predatory men
and women and
children how would it be the case that a
movement that ostensibly gave women more
freedom uh it decoupled their having sex
from always having to potentially carry
babies it liberated them to be a part of
the workforce how would it be that women
ended up on the receiving end of
something that had a lot of promises to
make life better well this is why I've
spent two books trying to explain these
paradoxes books called Adam and Eve
after the pill and Adam and Eve after
the pill Revisited because it is a lot
of paradoxical Fallout so let's go back
to say the early 1960s before most
people listening were born for example
and back in those days which I don't
remember either there was a lot of Hope
about the Advent of the birth control
pill about reliable
contraception uh that was almost
foolproof and you can see why people
were hopeful people said that it would
strengthen marriage for example to
Empower couples to have control over
their fertility people said that the
pill would reduce abortion this by the
way was Margaret sanger's argument for
contraception she believed that it would
reduce
abortion and so despite all of these
hopes the opposite seemed to happen so
within a few years of the adoption of
widespread hormonal
contraception instead of strengthening
marriage what we saw was a sharp rise in
divorce rates later in
cohabitation instead of the pill and
Company reducing abortion abortion rates
skyrocketed um into the millions within
a few years of this same cultural change
so what I'm trying to do in my research
is piece together why this happened and
I'm doing it with the help of uh
perfectly secular sources these are not
books of theology you don't have to
believe anything about religion to
understand the arguments of the books
and I think that's important to
establish because this kind of talk
about what happened after the birth
control pill what did the sexual
Revolution really do tends to get
confined to a religious ghetto and I
think it's important that people
understand that the the reality is upon
us whatever you believe you can be an
atheist you can be a devout Muslim you
can be anything you want but you still
have to understand that the effects of
this Revolution have been epic and in
more areas than one okay let's talk
about abortion then how
does
contraception reduce or increase
abortions what what are the outcomes of
introducing
it it does not reduce abortion
contraception increases abortion by
changing
intentionality and this is something
else that has been well studied and U
that I talk about in the footnotes to
these books but essentially what
contraception does is make pregnancy a
woman's problem and this is the big
cultural change that we
see back before there was reliable
contraception uh it was assumed that an
unplanned pregnancy was a problem for
two people and that they had to figure
out what to do about it the man was
expected to Bear some
responsibility but once women are
contracepting on Moss clearly uh
pregnancy is a a quote failure uh that
is her fault her
responsibility I'm not defending that
Outlook I'm explaining the the change in
thinking that resulted once
contraception became
unremarkable and that's where abortion
comes in or to put it another way uh the
uh the adoption of contraception
effectively ended the so-called shotgun
wedding I assume that's an American
phrase I think people people will know
what that is right it's it's intuitively
obvious right the dad and the brothers
show up at the boyfriend's house and say
marry the girl or else and once again
after the
1960s that phrase uh became antiquarian
which tells you something interesting I
think it tells you that expectations
were radically changed now the effect
this has had on men is something else
that we to talk about I Rely here on the
work of a sociologist named Lionel tiger
who wrote a book in 1999 called the
decline of males and once again tiger is
not a religious thinker he even said
that he regarded religion as toxic but
what he was trying to understand was
what the sexual Revolution did to men
because he argued once women have sole
control uh over reproduction men are
essentially sidelined and pretty useless
frankly so decades before everyone was
talking about the crisis of men in our
time this sociologist tiger was seeing
it very clearly and prophetically I
think how would it be the case or why
would it be the case that women having
control over reproduction decreases the
necessity of
men because it reduces their role as
protectors as
fathers it says to the world what the
message that the sexual revolution has
sent to the world which is autonomy is
all that counts and so suddenly you have
this radical cultural message which I
believe most people in our time have
adopted that Sidelines the traditional
family that takes away from men what
some of us believe is the Grandeur of
being a a provider and a protector and
this is why we have seen single parent
homes that is to say fatherless homes
proliferate because the social
approbation for the traditional male
role is missing and has gone missing
because of the sexual Revolution okay so
you get an increase in
abortions you get an increase in out of
wedlock births you get an increase in
single parent households which are
almost exclusively mother single mother
households fatherless
homes men don't have the same protector
provider
uh Glory perhaps that would have
previously been bestowed on them is
there because obviously we're talking
about sexual Revolution and
contraception here what happens is there
such a thing as a sexual Revolution
without the introduction of the
contraception pill could you could you
imagine what that would look
like people argue over definitions of
the sexual Revolution but I think this
one is pretty
uncontroversial the sexual Revolution
begins in the 1960s with the approval of
the birth control pill which is then
quickly adopted Across the Western World
we're not just talking about the United
States
and the effect of that is to
destigmatize non-marital sex because the
pill becomes like uh something that
everybody wants to have contraception
and the adoption thereof becomes a a
like a big wild party that everybody
wants to go to for understandable
reasons I mean we're human beings and if
you were to ask most people uh what they
would enjoy most in life sex without
consequences pretty high up on that list
I think so you know it's important to
understand this Chris because so often
people who take a critical look at these
phenomena the sexual Revolution
contraception broken homes Etc are
accused of wanting to go back to the
1950s you know they're accused of uh
being retrograde somehow and I don't
think those charges are fair I think we
can have a lot of empathy empathy for
why the sexual Revolution took hold and
a lot of understanding of the human
human motivations at work back then that
are still at work now but also we can
use our reason to see what the Fallout
of this thing has been because in my
estimation it has been more bad than
good you think it's a net negative
overall I do and I think there are
different kinds of proof for that so for
example there's Pro from the popular
culture uh in one chapter of one of my
books I go through the music of the
1990s for example when Eminem is the Big
Bad Boy Rap
Superstar and I dig into not only his
lyrics but the lyrics of most of the
bands that were prominent at the time
because I think they give us clear
evidence from the popular culture that
the post-revolutionary age is not a good
age for kids why do I say that well what
are the themes that Eminem and many
other rappers and Rockers are talking
about during those years they're talking
about how angry they are at their uh
absent fathers they're talking about how
dysfunctional the adults in their lives
are they're talking about and this is
particularly true of Eminem The need to
protect a younger sibling from the
adults in life who can't be trusted
these are deep themes and they speak to
uh a hurt out there that I don't think
has been correctly understood and it's
why I try to do justice to it in my work
so there from just one aperture onto the
popular culture I think we see clear
evidence that the post-revolutionary
world is not okay by the kids I think
that's a really interesting Insight
because if you were to begin a
conversation sexual reevolution ution
contraception uh and
rap where most people would think that
you were going to go would be the
objectification of women right that you
can now that you've got consequences
free sex this means that the the rappers
can talk about my my hoes and my
and stuff like that but it's not it's
about what has been the lived experience
and the felt experience of those rappers
when they were growing up and especially
if you're some guy from the hood
somewhere in
America
why were you growing up in a fatherless
home well it was largely facilitated in
some situations by the sexual Revolution
and the contraceptive bill yeah I mean
the misogyny is there there's no sugar
coating that but I'm trying to look
deeper into this genre of music so for
example let's look at a song by Tupac
Shakur uh called Papa's song it was one
of his most popular and it is one of the
saddest set of lyrics I've ever seen
it's about a boy trying to play catch by
himself that's what the song is about
and it's addressed uh to his father by
apotheosis um and he's talking about
what that's like to try to play catch by
yourself so there we have again evidence
that this music is speaking to millions
of kids it was kids who put all of the
guys uh on the top of the charts
millions and millions of uh kids boys
mostly turning out for the likes of
Eminem and others wrapping about how sad
their childhoods were and how angry they
were at the adults and this continues
beyond the 1990s but it's there I think
that we really see this pivot that's so
important there was a big debate in La
uh a few days ago about the sexual
Revolution one of my friends Louise
Perry who you might be familiar with her
work was was one of the participants and
Grimes who's a music artist she was on
the the opposite side a few other people
as well one of my friends Rob Henderson
tweeted saying there's lots of
discussion at the sexual Revolution
debate about whether the revolution
failed men or failed women or helped men
more than women or helped women more
than men nobody asked whether the sexual
Revolution failed children people
already know it's too depressing a
topic that's absolutely
spoton and I'm aware of the conference
you're describing and I have to say it's
really encouraging it's one of the
Grounds for Hope that say 10 years ago
when I published my first book Adam and
Eve after the pill on this subject there
was very little discussion outside
religious Circles of these issues there
was a kind of omera uh reigning
libertarianism about the subjects in my
book like pornography like what has this
done to kids like what is this doing to
romance and it's really heartening to
see that now this is this debate is
taking place uh not only in the United
States but in various countries of the
west by people with no interest in
religion in many cases and it's a clear
example of how ideas do percolate if you
keep hammering at them long enough and I
think it's a very healthy sign that um
ordinary westerners are starting to ask
these questions and that intellectuals
and journalists are starting to think
that this is important to cover what
about divorce rates what did the sexual
Revolution do to them they also
skyrocketed in the 1970s and into the
1980s and they seem to have stabilized
since then but for the reason that so
many people have dispensed with marriage
in the first place so in other words
cohabitation rates uh have risen uh
sharply ever since the
1960s
and couple of notes to make about that
one is that Research indicates that
people who cohabitate are actually more
likely to break up than people who marry
um this was also the kind of thing that
was once wildly controversial to put out
there but it is now very well
established in social science and the
other problem of course is that the RIS
risks of abuse to children are highest
in homes without a biological father
it's like 40 a 40 times increase I think
yes yes and that's a statistic that is
an indictment of society I think and I
don't say that to point fingers at any
individual family situation but the
social science is unambiguous and it has
been for
decades Okay so we have this raw
objective data coming out of demography
coming out of social sciences Melissa
carne's new book the two parent
Advantage you know looks at this through
a policy wonk DC lens right there's very
little ideology coming into
this how is it the case that the debate
and the discussion around this is so fra
a topic why is the truth or why was the
truth about the sexual Revolution and
the contraceptive pill being repressed
how does this sort of fold into culture
and and and why this discussion has been
so
abhor well once again getting back to
that image of the the wild party that
was started by the sexual Revolution to
continue the metaphor I think we're at
the point where it's 2 in the morning
and the party is out of control and
everybody knows it but nobody wants to
be the first one to snitch right nobody
wants to be the first one to call the
police or the ambulance or whatever it
is that the party needs at this point
again I think that former omera has been
broken and I'm very happy to see that
that it is um that's a good
thing so I understand
that first order happiness of
satisfaction like immediate
gratification of our based desires I
want to have sex I don't want anybody to
tell me that it's immoral or unethical
or whatever and I would like to not use
a condom and I would like so on and so
forth
right but if the outcomes are genuinely
negative for women I would have presumed
that this would have been you know the
campaign for feminists to have been
flying the flag for like this should
have been Ground Zero for feminists that
are looking at the data who want the
best for women in terms of outcomes what
why is this not you know the why is this
not the front Vanguard of fourth W
feminism I think feminism took a a wrong
turn a long time ago after the
1960s and stopped putting women first in
that sense so let me give you an example
uh another thing I talk about in the
books is pornography and the effects of
pornography on human
relationships and the relation of
relationship between pornography and the
sexual Revolution now back in the 1960s
even into the
1970s there were feminists who said you
know what this stuff is is bad this smut
is bad for Human
Relationships uh we should be against it
it objectifies women um and you could
hear those voices including some pretty
radical
feminists it all seemed to go
away feminism seemed to buy into a kind
of
libertarianism uh that benefited men and
so by the 1980s in 1990s instead you
hear feminist voices defending
pornography as a woman's right and
something that no one has a right to
question and this is a sea change that I
think tells us a lot about what happened
when feminism stopped putting women
first now I think we're seeing another
course correction here and I think there
are feminist
voices asking about whether pornography
is okay or giving women permission to be
against this thing but of course it's
not just that pornography is bad for
women it's bad for romance which means
it's bad for both
sexes what's
the what is the legitimate feminist case
against pornography or only fans or
something like that why shouldn't it be
the case that a woman can be completely
liberated with her sexuality as much as
possible surely this was the the role of
the sexual Revolution was to remove the
constraints to allow women to fully be
whatever they wanted unlimited freedom
is a good thing
no there's pleasure and there's longterm
happiness and I think that's the
distinction we need to talk about at
this point so even now Chris if you were
to ask most women wherever they are in
the political Spectrum what they want
most in life most will still say they
want a husband and a family and the
problem is that the revolution made
these things a lot harder to get because
when the sexual Marketplace is flooded
with potentially available
Partners um it makes it it reduces the
incentives for men to settle down with
any single partner and that puts a major
barrier into marriage and hence having
children with in marriage and again uh
you don't have to take my word for it
there are some great economists who have
studied this question and then they're
in the footnotes of these books as
well have you considered
the reduction in the standards that men
will meet in order to get sex if sex is
more easily available to
them so if if a man in order to be able
to get access to sex needs to be an
upstanding member of Society with a good
job and he needs to be well known in the
local community he needs to attend
church he needs to you know ask the
father of the daughter before he can get
down on one knee like the the mo the
hardest gatekeeper in her entire life he
needs to somehow get past him then he
needs to get down on one knee perhaps
there's a dowy perhaps you know all the
then there's a ceremony and all of the
people come and then finally finally he
gets to have sex
right that required men to meet
a pretty thorough set of criteria right
there's a lot of Hoops that you need to
jump through this isn't to say that all
men that got married before 1950 were
like upstanding citizens but there's a
lot more to
happen if the alternative is you need to
be in the right place at the right time
at 3:00 a.m. in a
nightclub men will meet those standards
appropriately and
the listlessness of men and the death of
eligible
partners that women compl you know where
are all of the Good Men at is a a huge
meta meme that that women talk about uh
you know if men can get sex without
investing in themselves to get
themselves to the standard that
previously would have been held for them
in order to have got sex which have
included the father's hand in marriage
the marriage the ceremony the house all
the rest of this stuff I think that it
seems to
me the reduction in men's standards the
the standard that they take themselves
to can be laid at at least partly at the
feet of the reduction in what women ask
in order for men to be able to get
access to
sex yeah that's a very interesting point
I think there's been a lowering of the
standards for both sexes but I think the
biggest problem here is that um men are
not being given their due frankly
they're not being given things to live
up to and strive for including the
privilege of protecting a a woman and
children the idea that that's even a
privilege is dangerously close to being
lost in our culture and instead what we
have are millions of young men who are
in so involved in pornography that it's
kind of game over for
romance if that weren't true we wouldn't
have therapists who
treat men and boys for this and the fact
that we do tells us something it tells
us that there's harm here this is
evidence of harm that people show up to
therapists saying I've got a problem uh
with this
substance um so again part of what I'm
trying to do here is just change the
terms of debate so that it's not about
exhorting people it's not about beating
people up for being bad it's about
trying to honor the the misery and the
suffering that underlies statistics like
that about pornography use or about of
the rise in female unhappiness over the
past couple of decades yeah we're
hearing an awful lot about the
psychological fragility of young people
especially young girls where do you
think that's coming
from I think social media as many have
pointed out is throwing gasoline on a
fire that's already raging and I think
the fire that's already raging is about
what I call human subtraction so let me
walk through this what really did the
sexual Revolution
do it subtracted people out of other
people's lives whether by abortion by
Family breakup
fatherlessness family
shrinkage all of these are acts of
subtraction and what they mean is that
for example a 20-year-old today has many
fewer people on average to whom he is
related whether in nuclear family or
extended family many kids are growing up
as only children many kids don't have a
sibling of the opposite sex or a father
in the home now why does this matter it
matters because we are social creatures
we are like other animals we learn by
observing others of our kind and I think
what we've done is radically reduced the
number of people from whom we can learn
Elementary lessons like what is the
opposite sex
like uh without going to the internet to
find out um we have reduced the number
of people in our Lives who can be
trusted to love and protect us and this
has been a profound change I think and I
believe it is reflected in the rising
rates of psychiatric trouble with kids
which actually predates the internet
this is something I've been writing
about for 20 years now because it's at
least 20 years since the rise in anxiety
and depression and other problems among
adolescence was well
established and everyone agrees now that
that was not something that Rose because
we were more aware of it that the rates
of these problems are actually rising
and continue to rise I think part of of
their reason in one word is loneliness
because the sexual Revolution took away
people yeah there's this
strange like Mass solipsism thing going
on at the moment right like this
atomized individualized all that matters
is me my pleasure in the immediate
convenience and comfort at at the
expense of everything else and um not a
a single uni-dimensional problem right
it's it's led into by helicopter
parenting it's contributed to by moving
from a Brawn based to a brain-based
economy where you don't actually need to
be in connection with your work quite
soop physically anymore you know the all
the way
down yeah uh there's a lot going on but
I do think the reduction in Social
knowledge is at the root of a lot of it
let me give you a homely example of I
was talking with a radio host once off
the air about this same notion that we
just lack people there's a people
deficit and a love deficit out there and
he told me a story about one of his kids
who had gotten involved in the diaper
business she had gotten involved in uh
making cloth diapers which you know are
enjoying a rebound um uh for ecological
reasons so she started selling these
things and very often the new mothers
would get in touch with her and say well
but wait a minute how do you put this on
and she realized that women were coming
to Motherhood with no experience of
babies and so it was good for her
because she expanded her business but
the point is think about it before the
sexual Revolution How likely would it
have been that a woman would get to the
age of of 18 say without knowing how to
take care of a baby or a toddler I think
the likelihood would have been very low
and yet now because of the people
deficit I'm describing because of the
diminishment of social knowledge about
basic things like how to take care of
other people it's entirely possible for
a woman or a man to reach middle age
without ever having held a
baby we have inflicted a wound on
ourselves that we're only beginning to
understand and I think for the sake of
human happiness and for the sake of the
people who are wounded in this way we
need to understand it to to get to a
less divisive place what would you say
to the people that respond Mary looking
after a child below the age of 18 or
even below the age of 25 that doesn't
sound like fun I've got a career to go
after I've got an academic Pursuit that
I'm doing and then on I finished that
I'm the job market and financial
Independence and exploring the world and
myself and learning about myself and
growing what you're suggesting here
sounds ancestral and patriarchal and and
restrictive so I would say to that
person that nurture is like a muscle and
if we don't use it it atrophies and it
is not the fault of people today that
most of us don't grow up say with an
aging relative in the home as also used
to be common and fewer and fewer of us
grow up in families of size where there
are babies and toddlers around reliably
but the point is that taking care of
other people is part of what humanizes
US and the fact that we are not called
upon to do that very much anymore or
that we choose not to call upon
ourselves elves to do that isn't good
for
us that's the point that I'm trying to
drive home to get back to the social
science again since the moan report
since the 1960s all of these issues have
been studied everybody knows the sexual
revolution has had some very bad effects
and if social science convinced people
then we would be living in a different
world by now and I'm not saying that to
knock the social science it's important
it's important to know where the truth
is but we need something else to get
through to people uh so that they
understand what has changed about the
world what's bad for them about this
change um and how to get to a better
place and that again is what I'm trying
to describe in my work I saw some stats
social science stuff saying that
previously women used to be happier than
men on average and now women are less
happy than men on average now both men
and women's happiness over the last 50
years has decreased but women have gone
from being above to being below and men
have just dropped down a little bit
uh I
mean if the story that we were told
about increased freedom and Liberation
was true we shouldn't have seen this
effect and I would be interested in
asking a you know card carrying sex
positive uh feminist person how do you
explain this decrease in happiness among
women if ostensibly over the last 50
years all of the things if you'd asked a
woman 50 years ago maybe 60 years ago if
you'd ask them what is it that you would
like for your life or for your
daughter's lives you know all of those
things have been handed to them and as
your work
identifies what on the surface sounds
like a
fantastic uh wonderful Liberation often
has second and third and fourth other
consequences that are wild ly unseen and
may end up not only negating the
advantage but actually setting people
back more than they were
originally again back to that
distinction between pleasure and
happiness so the technological shock of
reliable contraception for women made
pleasure much easier to attain for both
sexes um 3 in the morning in the club
kind of pleasure as you put it uh but
simultaneously it made long-term
fulfillment more difficult to secure and
that's the biggest Paradox that we are
living with how do you change
expectations when they've become so
ingrained you know it won't be long
before nobody alive remembers life
before the sexual Revolution I don't um
and I'm not again not saying let's go
back to some Golden Age there's no such
thing as a golden age but we need to
recover the truth that radical autonomy
is not in our best interests any more
than it's in the best interests of say
Elephants or dolphins or other mammals
um we are social creatures like they are
and the ironic thing Chris is that if we
look at other species we understand very
well that they need each other those
horrible experiments on the rees's
monkeys separating the babies from the
mothers showing how dysfunctional the
babies became when they were separated
from their own kind you know this kind
of thing makes sense to us and we look
back on that and think oh that was a
horrible thing to do to the monkeys just
as we think now it was a horrible thing
for circuses say to take individual
elephants and separate them from their
families and so we don't do that anymore
the ironic thing is we don't seem to be
able to hold the mirror up to ourselves
and to see that we are running that same
kind of radical experiment on Homo
sapiens yeah I mean think about when you
the videos
of zoos where the pen is way too small
for the animal and it's not able to roam
around and it's not got fresh air and
it's in the corner doing a very sort of
strange compulsive
Behavior tell me how different that is
to somebody living in a box apartment
somewhere in some un for giving
Cosmopolitan City swiping through Tik
Tok like it is the same thing right it's
not a screen addiction that people have
it's a screen compulsion that they have
and one uh interesting point we were
talking about sort of romance and the uh
socializing effect that uh helps people
to become better communicators more
generally when you're around family
members I just thought about something
this is me bro sciencing in real time
here so you might need to give me a
little bit of a little bit of rope
one of my friends who's very successful
with women said that the
best advice that he could give any young
guy who wants to be successful with
women is have lots of female friends
when you're in your teenagers because
it's low stakes communication it teaches
you how to communicate with the other
the other sex it you're not trying to do
anything so there's no such thing really
as failure other than the natural sort
of highs and lows of friendship and and
coming and going and falls out and all
the rest of it I wonder if a
uh extended family Pang generational
Homestead style situation that would
have been at least post-agricultural
Revolution for a good chunk of time or
pre-agricultural revolution in terms of
tribes you're you're not going to have
sex with your sister you're not probably
going to have sex with your cousins so
what it creates There is almost this
precise scenario of training wheels for
males and females as they grow up up to
learn how to communicate with the other
sex very low stakes no expectation
doesn't really matter if you get it
wrong because their family they've kind
of got to love you in any case and then
by the time that you get to the stage
where you do actually need to
communicate with somebody who is outside
of your own gene pool you've accumulated
enough background and and skills that
you can actually maybe make it work what
do you think about my my bro science
theory I think that's absolutely spot on
nailed it yeah go Chris yeah
it's how we used to learn about each
other we have multiple examples of the
other sex in our families and extended
families and that would teach us
something I think part of the
belligerent rhetoric of contemporary
feminism is actually covering up a fear
a fear and an insecurity that is coming
about because a lot of women don't know
much about men anymore they haven't had
that experience in the home and I'm not
saying that's the only place fearfulness
comes from they're of course threats um
real
threats but similarly I think a lot of
what we see I think especially online
this animosity toward women sometimes
coming from the Bros you know this sort
of
uh
um phenomenon of the hes and whatever
they're called this reflexive misogyny
again I think some of that is also
coming from the same place which is
ignorance of the opposite sex just not
understanding the first thing
about what it's like to deal with the
opposite sex and trying to cover it up
in the case of men with this kind of um
cheap misogyny this free floating
misogyny and in the case of women with
this kind of belligerent feminism that
Apes male tropes and insists on a kind
of toughness to cover up the fact that
people are
insecure this goes back to talking about
the the teenagers and the you know
20-some out there who really seem
clueless um and it's not their fault
part of what I'm trying to do here is
give people permission to understand
that they're misery their loneliness is
not of their making and it's not as if
we can point backwards in time and
finger the real culprits there are some
names that come to mind um Hugh Hefner
would be one for example Helen Gurley
Brown didn't help uh there are more but
the point is this was not an intentional
plot we did something to ourselves not
understanding how serious it would be
and then that's what we have to face now
yeah I love it I love it I'm thinking an
awful lot about reducing the adversarial
nature between the Sexes right that
there is an anti- mating mating culture
at the moment men and women are enemies
they are resources to be extracted from
they are enemies to be avoided entirely
or to be used and discarded um you know
it's it's it's almost like a virtual
reality game of trying to be a human
it's like you go through all of the
Motions you're the the the philosophical
zombie of the relationship world where
you try and do all of the actions and do
all of the things that you kind of think
you're supposed to do but you don't feel
any of the things that you're supposed
to feel because you know that the risk
is so high because it's just transient
and transactional and on to the next one
so you know the fear of being ghosted or
left behind or hurt in some way uh
because that happens and yeah I I think
it's
the the natural human response is okay
whose fault is it who's to blame who can
we hang drawer and quarter so that we
can say ah yeah it was this it was this
particular person you know the
scapegoating rally around whoever it is
that got it
wrong but telling people that from first
principles think you are in the 1960s
and you have this world changing uh
technological innovation that was the
contraceptive pill you have a time where
women want to not be beholden
financially to their husband anymore
they don't want to have to stay in
abusive or terrible marriages simply
because they're going to be out on the
street with two and a half children and
a dog if they if they don't stay with
their partner that beats them or or
doesn't care about them or is you know
is awful or whatever it might be and
you're given this technology that on the
face of it allows women to be liberated
from situations in which they would have
had it would have been would have been
bad it would have been terrible for them
and this means that we can get into
University this means that we can have
parity in terms of pay this means that
we can have parity in terms of
socioeconomic status all of those things
here is the freedom like that's a really
really fantastic deal and EV very very
few people if anyone had been able to
see the second and third order effects
of
this they're a genius they're a
clairvoyant Super Genius right with with
astral realm
abilities and yet you can look back on
it and say
we couldn't predict this Downstream it's
caused some effects that nobody expected
to
happen and it's almost it's almost a
little bit like the uh Gambler chasing
his
losses that we we thought that this was
going to be good and accepting that it's
not potentially opens up a whole world
of of difficult
conversations and uh yeah right now
the change in culture that I'm seeing is
not this like card carrying like you say
it's not coming from a religious uh
standpoint it's not tradcon like hard
right conservatives trying to take women
out of the boardroom and put them back
in the kitchen it's just saying look at
what's happened with overall happiness
let's see if this is genuinely right for
what people want in life which is
fulfillment connection Health longevity
family that cares about them
so an analogy that comes to mind based
on what you were just saying is tobacco
smoking because you could say the same
thing about tobacco smoking that we've
said about the sexual Revolution when
that all started nobody could have seen
what was coming in other words tobacco
smoking was ubiquitous Across the
Western World and that was true for a
long time and I can actually remember as
a kid seeing people smoke in
hospitals that's probably not something
you remember but it was that common what
was the thing uh doctors smoke
camels that sounds right I mean you
shouldn't do it near an oxygen machine
but it was that common yeah so what
happened here we don't see that anymore
you can't smoke indoors uh practically
anywhere there's been an enormous change
in stigma stigma got attached to this
substance somehow how did that happen
and it happened because there was an
accumulation over half a century of
evidence that this substance tobacco
could cause harm and there was a lot of
resistance to that message nobody wanted
to hear it especially if you smoked you
certainly didn't want to hear that this
was bad for you but little by little the
accumulation of evidence and research
made a dent and again not just in one
country but Across the Western World and
across the non-western world this
substance has been made uh less
ubiquitous and people smoke a lot less
than they used
to so my point is we might be at the
very beginning of the equivalent of the
surgeon general's report we might be at
the very beginning of people pushing
back and saying look there's evidence
that we are harming ourselves through no
fault of our own and we need to get a
little more of a balance here we need to
get back to some kind of normal that
isn't the normal that we have and so
maybe 50 years from now all of this will
look different talk to me about how in
such a sex positive world so many people
seem to be checking out of mating
altogether right now there's basically a
widespread stigmatization of traditional
sexual morality
yes and there's a widespread
destigmatization of all forms of sexual
behavior uh apart from Marriage it is
kind of
interesting so what does sex positivity
have to do with this again I think if
you have to resort to a term like sex
positivity you're protesting too much
like what are you not getting about this
why do you need make some public
statement about something that up until
say the
1960s people thought was ordinary normal
behavior so that's what I'm hearing in
what you're saying is that the fact that
we have words like that sex positivity
to make us feel good about
ourselves tells me again that there's a
lot of disconnection out there of the at
the most fundamental level yeah I
wouldn't disagree whatever you
whatever nman clature you want to give
to it there is a a sex is front and
center of an awful lot you know even
girl advice magazines how to sleep with
him and not catch feels you know some of
the most popular female podcasts on the
planet in fact one of the biggest ones
was a many a multi-year diet tribe about
the Perils of relationships and getting
and and too much commitment and and you
know the
pedestalize with people who you didn't
know name and all this sort of stuff and
yet we have some of the highest rates of
men especially but also women saying
that they're not interested in
short-term or long-term relationships at
all and this to me seems to be another
Paradox culture that says casual sex is
great and also that you know mating and
dating is completely on your terms so
there's never
been more different ways that you can do
mating and and yet there's never been so
many people electing to check out of
mating altogether how does that how do
you square this
circle yeah when I
hear what you're describing women
talking about how great it is to be as
free for casual sex as men I find that
very sad because what I'm hearing in
that is Stockholm Syndrome if we can't
get reliable men we will secure them by
male means we will ape the opposite sex
and try and be as tough and predatory um
as its worst members can
be it's Stockholm syndrome it's not
Liberation it's
sad yeah it's
um the modern women are being taught
that true Liberation is working like
their father and having sex like their
brother and
I mean you know I don't know how
powerful the patriarchy is but it may
very well have managed to convince women
that they can not only be the bread
winner for the relationship while the
husband stays at home and plays Xbox but
that they can also give
up no strings attached sex to men that
either don't care about them or maybe
even actively dislike them so maybe the
patriarchy is is in charge all along I
don't
know well one of the worst things about
our moment is that women have lost a
sense of their own Grandeur you know
both sexes have such a diminished
understanding of what it means to be a
man what it means to be a woman there's
glory in being a woman and when it feels
as if the culture is sending the message
that the only way to succeed as a woman
is to be more like a man we are getting
something really wrong wrong here and we
are ironically disempowering people
there's glory in marriage there's glory
in motherhood those are not statements
of nostalgia there are statements about
how much richer Our Lives become when we
take radical leaps like marriage like
childbearing and the excitement of that
the the glamour of that
frankly is lost on people we need to
bring it back how is the sexual
Revolution related to Identity
politics so here's an interesting fact I
think the first use of that phrase
identity politics comes about in
1977 it appears in a Manifesto by
radical African-American feminists
called the kahi river Collective and in
this document which again is one of the
documents that point points to the
sadness of the years after the 60s these
women declare that they are giving up on
men they are giving up on the men in
their lives the the words fathers and
brothers do not even appear in this
statement the statement is all about how
we can only trust people who are just
like us in our victimhood to understand
ourselves uh we can only trust those
people to have our back now why is that
interesting well first of all because
1977 is just as the young adults uh Born
Into the revolution are starting to come
of Age and what do we see we see a kind
of shattering and we see uh what becomes
the first episode in identity
politics so let's fast forward a few
decades now we're surrounded by identity
politics um everybody is a victim
everybody joins a group everybody um
involved in this kind of politics treats
their group in the way that say the
family used to be treated this is my
chosen family uh whether it's lgbtq or
something based on race or ethnicity or
whatever the grouping is they all share
this common
denominator of having their political
identity become a substitute for what I
think were the old ways of establishing
identity what would those be well first
of all people lived in families what was
your identity I'm a mother I'm an aunt
I'm a cousin I'm a sister etc
etc again thanks to the shrinkage of the
family that kind of answer is off the
table for many people they can't answer
that question Who Am I by pointing to
their relationships within a family it's
it's too complicated what if I have step
siblings and half siblings and my
father's on his third divorce it's
complicated um what is not complicated
is that this implosion of the family has
left a lot of people disconnected and
feeling in need of protection and
wanting to attach to something we're
relational creatures we have to attach
to something we can't actually live like
autonomous
electrons and so the rise of identity
politics I think directly parallels what
we've been talking about which is the
implosion of the family family networks
Etc didn't you they become substitute
families for people who don't have the
real thing yeah I mean the human draw
toward tribalism is so great that you
will just start constructing arbitrary
tribes if you can't find one that seems
to make sense yeah and again loneliness
is the driver here it's about not
wanting to be lonely it's about wanting
to go online and have your Vindication
and the number of likes you get from
your group for performing some uh
totemic act if you will uh it's about
being rewarded and feeling loved and
feeling all these things that we all
want to feel in a time when many people
don't seem to be feeling them in real
life and that's what's driving identity
politics and the problem with it is that
it is deforming the politics of the
western world to have
groups um that are absolutist about
other groups that are absolutist in
stating that no one else outside the
group can understand
them it's a problem yeah what about um
changes in sort of sexual behavior and
confusion around whether it be Identity
or orientation
is have you drawn any lines between the
sexual Revolution and
that yeah I think it's interesting
because so many people profess shock at
the phenomenon of transgenderism for
example whereas from what I've read and
researched and written about shock is
the last thing I feel when you think
about the confusion we have generated
among ourselves going back to the lack
of social knowledge about the opposite
sex for example when you think about the
messages sent to boys and girls in homes
without fathers for example boys absorb
the message that men are bad because
very often fatherless homes are
fatherless because Dad was bad um and
girls absorb the message that men are
not to be
trusted so where does that leave them I
think it leaves us with this weird
incentive um for the disconnected to
grab gravitate toward an androgynous
mean to gravitate away from Poles of say
femininity and masculinity and toward
something that doesn't look as scary as
those things because I it's uh more anod
than those
things just a
theory look I I I think everything's
kind of on the table at the moment
there's definitely an awful lot going on
and I had Melissa Carnie uh who wrote
the two parent advantage on recently and
I think a book come comes out today
actually and it's causing all manner of
a storm on Twitter which is just
fantastic
uh it doesn't surprise me and I think
this is probably worth driving home
again
that people are confused and struggling
right that life it's easy to say the
world has never been more convenient and
comfortable and and this is all the the
the pains and the complaints that you've
got it's this Bourgeois speaking down
from on high sort of like wanky
Aristocrat complaint about a world that
you really shouldn't but it's there's
from a felt sense that a lot of people
have they're lost you know they they
they're struggling they don't have the
role models they don't have the
archetypes to follow anymore especially
if you're my generation Millennials or
younger the step change between your
parents generation and ours was so great
you have parents born in the 60s and'
70s that grew up without
technology or without certainly without
sort of portable technology that was
widespread to now okay so Mom and Dad
what are you going to teach me about how
to navigate Tik Tok and and deep fakes
and and and nudes and leaked screenshots
and and group chats and Instagram and
you know all that St online bullying it
you know it is a a time of massive
turbulence and a lot of the things that
people feel like the shame that people
feel for
almost they castigate themselves and and
feel resentful that they're not able to
take advantages of a world that they
feel has been given to them and I think
that yeah the the one of the like front
runner emotions that we should be
feeling is like understanding in
sympathy
absolutely I think also we're at the
beginning of a renorming about social
media and screens and the internet and
all of that stuff generally and again
it's not our faults exactly we got
flooded with this stuff and kids are
flooded with this stuff you know like
the Gin alleys of
London in the Victorian era and before
were flooded with Jin and babies
drinking Jin and pregnant women drinking
Jin wasn't thought to be a bad thing U
it took it took an Awakening uh and a
lot of Reform to ameliorate that problem
um but I think the fact that the
architects of Silicon Valley don't give
these toys to their own kids and send
their own kids to schools where these
things are not in play tells us a lot so
one reason I'm hopeful is that I think
in 10 years 20 years we'll have much
better strategies for keeping kids from
diving down that rabbit hole and not
coming out
yeah yeah it is a a machine gun fire
from all angles of of new stimulus right
new stimuli that nobody actually has an
understanding about how to how to get
around you looked at didn't you look at
some stuff to do with life expectancy as
well wasn't that related to
it yeah well couple of things about that
one life expectancy has been dropping in
the United States for the first time in
recorded history and some of that is due
to the opioid epidemic which became a
heroin epidemic which became a synthetic
methamphetamine and heroin epidemic that
we are still living through in the
United States drug deaths are at record
highs and there's a lot of theorizing
about that I I would go back to the
question why are people so drawn to
these things and I don't mean that as a
Pana kind of question we all know
there's nothing more powerful than the
morphine molecule say but clearly the
fact that millions of people are part of
this tells us that there's there's a
hole there there's something there that
is not being filled by uh say working
with your hands working in a field
coming home to a family Etc so the drug
problem I think is is partly again
pointing to what we've done to ourselves
second thing about life
expectancy the hardest stuff that I've
had to read for my research is actually
not about kids even though a lot of kids
are imperiled today by the trends we're
talking about it's about old people
because what has happened is that the
implosion of the family has left many
other vulnerable people at the other end
of life uh unattached
so for example in sociology there's been
an explosion of things called loneliness
studies it's it's a really hot stock if
you wanted to be a sociologist today go
into loneliness studies because I'm sure
there's a lot of grant money there and
rightly so so why is this you can just
Google it Google loneliness studies and
any country in the western world what's
happened is that the generations of
people who have bought into the promises
of the sexual Revolution who lived as
autonomous people maybe not having
families maybe having a child uh Etc but
living in this radically unattached way
these people come to the end of life and
there's nobody there and that's what the
loneliness studies are about so again
clear evidence of harm is here we didn't
used to have studies like this we didn't
used to talk about the profound
loneliness of people at the end of life
for example uh in Germany I seem to
remember from some study uh some
incredible number of people over the age
of 80 have not been called by their
first name in the past month because
there's no one around who knows them
well enough to do
that these facts tell us something that
again
ought to be addressed so what I'm trying
to do is summon evidence from from all
over from the popular culture from
sociology from reading about the misery
that young men and women especially seem
to be experiencing these days and just
wrap it all up and say here this is what
we have to deal with the good news is we
know what the problem is now so let's
start what does starting mean to you
in part it means listening and what I
mean by that is
that it's very easy to
dismiss say young people
say the Millennials and the Zoomers as
snowflakes right it's very easy to
dismiss the sensitivities that come with
identity politics it's very easy to
dismiss phenomena like students with
their mouths duct tape shut marching
around on campus and uh retreating to
Safe spaces and otherwise behaving in
these kind of retrograde ways it's easy
to mock that we have a lot of people in
public life who um make a living off it
and I understand why um because on the
surface on the surface it looks
ridiculous what I'm saying is underneath
that is suffering and we need to
understand where it's coming from so the
first thing to do to start fixing stuff
uh is to exercise our empathy muscles
which I think are pretty underutilized
these days yeah and to see the suffering
people around us whether we agree with
them about other things or or not um as
victims in the proper sense you know the
problem Chris is that these people
aren't victims of the things that
they've been taught they are victims of
they're not victims of quote the
patriarchy or
heteronormativity or other
abstractions those are very abstract
labels for what ails us and so I don't
respect them uh they are victims of this
phenomenon that started before most of
us were born uh that has had the effect
of producing a love deficit across the
West a people
deficit yeah it's hard to Rally a angry
mob holding placards against the love
deficit though do you know what I mean
or a technological Revolution that
happened 70 years
ago it's hard to Rally an angry mob
period Well I depends on evidence over
the last three years or
so again if facts were all it took to
convince people that you and I are right
about this because I think we're on the
same page about this then people would
have been convinced long
ago facts are not enough we need to find
a language that acknowledges that
suffering but also encourages people to
recognize it and move on because this is
the problem the problem is that there is
no redemption in this Grim new world of
ours the world of cancellation
doesn't allow a second chance and the
world of identity politics doesn't give
you a second chance if you are exiled
from the group you're dead or might as
well be and perversely this makes me
hopeful too
because people don't really believe that
there isn't Redemption nobody wants to
live in a world like that right we all
make mistakes we all need to come back
from things and so I think this the
severity of the cancel culture the
severity of identity politics is proving
already to be too much to bear and it
makes me hopeful that in five years
we'll be having a more reasonable
conversation across the aisle about that
stuff that is a future that I would look
forward to Mary IAT ladies and gentlemen
Mary I really appreciate you I think
that you've got a fantastic perspective
on all of this stuff where should people
go if they want to keep up to date with
the stuff that you're doing thank you
Chris I have a website Mary ever.com and
my books and articles and speeches are
there and uh the books are also on
Amazon of course Mary I appreciate you
thank you thank you Chris if you enjoyed
that episode then press here for a
selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to
[Music]
subscribe